the New York Post is reporting that out
of the 37,000 911 workers 2,500 of them
have cancer so we've got some more info
for you on this last year 1140 cases of
cancer were reported among ground zero
responders and rescuers but the number
now has grown to over 2500 911 workers
suffer from cancers at a much greater
rate than the general population
specifically lung cancer prostate cancer
thyroid cancer and leukemia uh so far
the B CF which is the victim
compensation fund has awarded a hundred
fifteen cancer patients with a total of
fifty point five million in sums ranging
from 400,000 to 4.1 million uh so you
know we when you think about 911
obviously you think about the thousands
of people that died you think about the
families that have to live with the
grief that kind of stuff and the
responder is sort of like you know
people that fight wars across the world
they come home and then we kind of
forget about them shouldn't we be
hearing a lot more about this yes but
why would they put these people in the
spotlight because it's a it just makes
everywhere and I'm not saying I feel
this way I'm saying this is why I think
that we don't it makes it brings up a
terrible memory in our very recent
history it makes people feel bad because
they feel powerless and it doesn't shine
I mean I don't really know how this
would be the government's fault i mean i
was i was there i was a few blocks up in
a horrible horrible day but people
running into danger knew that there are
risks running into danger so everyone
feels so powerless I mean and and as far
as cancers go these are pretty much the
worst prostate cancer thyroid cancer
these have a very very low rate of
survival so I I just don't know what I
don't necessarily know what the point is
and I don't mean it like that I just I
don't know how it benefits people
because there's nothing we can do except
what give them money right so I right so
we're giving them money but of course we
could probably give them better medical
care and there's all things
we probably can do that have nothing to
do with money I just one little
antidotal thing i was in new york city
owes on 911 and I lived on 90th and
first which if you know anything on your
say that's pretty far that's pretty far
lived on the far Upper East Side
literally about three hours after the
planes hit you could smell the the
burning debris you could smell and they
were stuff in the air route which went
on for days but I mean that something
about something it was extremely far
from where it happened so these people
who were right in the thick of it sadly
none of this is surprising why why don't
we do better for these people uh well I
think it it's sort of like the VA
scandal where we want these people to
oui oui tout them and we say we
appreciate your service everything but
we're gonna totally [ __ ] you over and
then we're gonna ignore forget you
forget about you and I think we have
done that entirely but for the most part
that's we do and I one thing that I
would like whenever we talk about the
ground zero responders and the cancer
rates on it is to remind people that the
UH Bush administration EPA chief Christy
Todd Whitman said three days after the
attacks that the air is perfectly safe
that we have evidence and we know the
air is perfectly safe don't worry about
it go right ahead and that in two years
later the EPA inspector general came out
with the report saying she had no basis
for saying that and she was sued and
then and in 2006 I have their that the
US District Judge Debra bats allowed a
lawsuit against women proceed and called
woman's actions conscience shocking I'll
but later on that finding was overturned
on appeal and women could not be was not
held liable for her comments so she face
no consequences and so it's it's not
only a stock that is right that more
scandal but it's also the
too-big-to-fail sort of like we're gonna
protect the upper the the the elites
they're not going to face any
consequences for this that's what it
that's it feels like in terms of a lot
of the military well it's not my kid I
you know I i can buy him out of this
situation but you people you're fine
just go and that's and I don't know all
the legal jargon I don't know any of the
legal jargon outside of watching a few
csi's but when you say that about
Christy Todd Whitman all I think I was
like shouldn't she be held for like
manslaughter yep that's murder if she
should be ashamed to show her face I
think I mean it's it's it's
unconscionable what she did and
but she faces no cops went no social no
political consequences she is I'm sure
gets 15 20 thousand dollars for speeches
or she toured the country I don't know
what she's doing she's in some think
tank but I mean so it isn't this is the
type of thing that we where President
Obama we were given a lot of crap last
week about fundraising for three days in
the middle of this whole everything with
middle eastern Russia in Ukraine all
that isn't this one of these things
where maybe he could say you know what
for the next video I'm a fundraise for
these people he raised around six
million for the DNC last week he could
just as easily raise six million for
these people so this is just pot like
this is the worst kind of but that also
sends the wrong message like we did like
we have to do special things for them
this should be built in but we should
have to do special things for them no we
should be built into the federal
government however we take care of these
people but that didn't happen it's been
13 years so now is the time for somebody
to stand up and do something Sean
Stewart job isn't it I think that is Jon
Stewart but the other thing is that this
is also the consequence of the bush
administration our failure to stop the
attacks and I mean the the all dying in
Iraq now the VA scandal the first
responders all the soldiers who died in
Iraq it's all because they did Elise
going all you could argue it's because
is a consequence of them ignoring the
PDB in august six 2001 saying that
people think about you know flying
planes into buildings yeah and it's it's
perfect
you